Mazes have fascinated us for tens of
thousands.
So if years from ancient wall drawings
to Greek and Roman mythology to modern
film mazes and labyrinths have on some
level always strongly resonated with the
human experience and seeing at a
symbolical layered deeper than the
merely physical experience you get from
exploring it's corridors,
which is a reason why I got intrigued by
Denis Villeneuve's 2014 film prisoners
and how it uses mazes as a symbol in
prisoners.
We never get to see amaze in its
physical form.
In fact,
the maize is not even billy explicitly
mentioned at all until later in the
story.
I look totally amazed that a map
guarding fundraisers remaining in the
background for the better first half of
the film,
yet it's significant.
Shoot,
not be understated as the nice film of
himself seems to have somewhat of a mild
obsession with these puzzles,
with characters having to venture
through both physical and mental
corridors,
trying not to lose themselves in search
of answers,
answers about family,
about what's right and what's wrong
about life,
death,
what connects us through language and
about faith in the face of evil.
If you'll notice,
puzzle is one that focuses on the
metaphorical and the psychological
symbolism of the maze,
rather than having it directly manifest
itself in its physical form.
Now,
most western May,
symbolism seems to be derived from the
Greek myth of theseus and the minutes
are which sells historian easiest,
who needs to find and kill a monstrous
beast at the center of the labyrinth
using a threat of hair from his lover
area.
Ariadne needs to make sure he doesn't
get lost along the way.
Now compare that to the story of
prisoners,
which is about the kidnapping of two
daughters and how the characters involve
choose to react in order to get them
back.
The main focus here is placed on to
character Keller Dover,
a religious and protective,
that who will do anything to keep his
family safe and who will ultimately find
the monster of his world with the help
of a young girl and Loki and ace
detective with a troubled background,
tasks of the mission to solve the
mystery and find a missing kids,
so only metaphorical level.
The maze in prisoners then seems to
loosely echoed as age old Greek myth.
Both these men set out on a search using
their own respective belief systems to
lead them through the metaphorical maze
of mystery and morality,
hoping to find the truth at the center
and to confront those responsible for
the kidnapping.
It perhaps more strikingly similar
connection can be found in Nordic
mythology involving a maiden horror
princess stuck in the center of the
maze,
again,
guarded by months,
creature of source,
the late poet Robert Graves,
argued that what these very stories have
in common is that they share a journey
of the main character into Bofi physical
as well as a mental underworld.
Keller nurturers daughter might be a
physical one,
but as his faith is challenged and he's
forced to confront the darker and more
violent parts of his nature,
his journey into the maze of the honor
ruled increasingly becomes a mental one,
so much so that his goal to protect his
family almost ends up destroying as he
neglects his traumatized wife and
increasingly regresses back into old
destructive habits and places until he'd
literally descends into his own darkest
place imaginable,
helpless and unable to save his
daughter.
Low key on the other hand,
has to unravel the truth by descending
into a more physical hell,
trying to find order and disorder and
literally facing off against the forces
of the devil
making children disappears.
The war we wage
the maze here seems to be a symbol for
the chaos to Jones is set up under
victims until they killed him off with
the venom of a snake,
the disciples symbol for the devil and
the archetype of the maze and prisoners
seems to stand for the opposite of
Paradise.
We're in the words of playwright Eugene,
UNESCO.
If goodness is order,
evil must be disordered,
straight path or the maze and it's if
this insight,
the Vilna of utilize this symbol to
explore it and morality in the
psychological nature of his character's
Keller starts off as an open league
devout Christian which has made quite
obvious through his usage of prayers
will be done on earth,
be abundance of Christian symbolism
surrounding him,
his metaphorically appropriate job as a
carpenter and through to names of his
wife and mother.
Moreover,
Keller was shown to have a proclivity
for orderliness and preparedness.
Both traits that consciously define his
character.
Hurry for the best,
prepare for the worst.
However,
as I've shown Keller's journey is one of
increasing amounts of disorder,
Aquestt that shakes his faith to at
score as he sees himself for super form
ever escalating brutalities on the
person he suspects holds the key to his
daughter.
Well,
he making me do this.
It's only at the end of this journey
when he's in his darkest place that he
finally surrenders and returns to his
faith in God.
Check mine.
Detective Loki goes down eight decidedly
different bath of the maze.
His faith is based in both the Christian
as well as the pagan.
The eight point,
it starts at two on his neck,
referring to such things as redemption.
Youmail.
The strength and compassion is Mason
Ring representing the search for
enlightenment and rationality,
aligning perfectly with his character
and the posing to more emotionally based
Geller,
his odd name and turn.
It comes from the Nordic God,
Loki gunning,
trickster and occasional helper of other
gods.
And even though the ace tech,
the fish show nuts to be immune to
frustration,
never truly breaks away from his
beliefs,
ultimately help them in finding the
missing children and solving the
mystery.
So besides acting as a symbol for the
physical and metaphorical journey and
judy underworld,
the also comes to represent a
psychological struggle.
And the human brain,
Stanley Kubrick show this in connection
with the growing and sanity of Jack
Torrance in the shining.
But it's also a symbolism.
It has ample historical grounding.
Both Christian and pagan famous around
the world have used a symbol of a linear
one way labyrinth as a meditative baff
way towards the center towards God self
and the tree of life.
Psychoanalysts,
Carl Young,
recognized labyrinths and similar
figures of centers,
sculpt Mandalis as a universally
recurring archetype always standing for
transformation,
wholeness,
and the totality of an individual's
reality.
The symbols can appear on the most
common of household objects and things
like below sweaters and picture frames
which are also expressed through
religion suggest a Christian Cross and
the tree of life.
It wouldn't cross as I've shown his
already abundantly represented them
prisoners,
but so was the tree of life.
In fact,
feel no spares,
no expense.
Focusing his lens on trees,
making them part of the plot and having
his main character interact with its
substance.
Trees undeniably take on an important
role in the film and it's no coincidence
that they too are connected to demand a
symbol and by extension the labyrinth
there.
Physical form is also a direct metaphor
for the human nervous system and the
psychological state of our characters
there.
Bare and leafless branches aligning with
our mood and mental state,
which brings us back to the maze used by
the Joneses.
Now it's important to know that this
particular maize is not a simple linear
one far from it.
There's a connection.
Okay.
Connection is,
it's the last amazing book.
There's no way out your core there.
LSD influenced May's processes
specifically designed to mentally
blocked our victims in their journey
towards self individualization.
It's a form of mind control that can
help explain why Alex seems to be stuck
in the mind of a 10 year old and why
Bobby Taylor,
although physically free is still
obsessive.
Lee trying to find a way out of his own
mental health,
but the maize is not just a tool for the
Joneses to imprison children and learn
their parents.
It also goes to show how some of the
characters had been stuck in there all
along.
It's revealed that gathers dad committed
suicide in his house when Keller himself
was still a team.
The contrast between his study house and
is the lap.
It's aided parental home and calories,
unwillingness to renovate the place.
Like I keep telling your mother it's an
old building will cost a fortune to fix
it up revealed to us that the death of
his father has still not been resolved
in his mind.
Keller self grove as a teen has been
stunted by this drama and in a way he is
as much a prisoner as Alex Jones and
Bobby Taylor has repressed feelings of
rage and despair,
awakened by the kidnapping of his
daughter.
Even killer's name meaning basement in
German,
speaks to his character is hidden away
mental trauma and foreshadows his
destiny perfectly.
Holly Jones on herter and has been a
prisoner of our own respect of maize for
quite some time after their son died of
cancer to one's devout Christians,
lost our faith and decided to best to
drag as many people into their mental
health was possible.
Even detective Loki seems to have
struggled with his own maze during his
troubled childhood.
You know what?
I spent six years old and having two
boys home and you know the Hunnington
boys hurting a fuck like you'd be a real
treat for me.
What you telling me the difference of
yours?
That Loki is the only one of these
characters who like in the story of
Andrea [inaudible] is elevated himself
from the mental trap raising his
consciousness in the process.
It's only fitting that he grows up to be
an ace detective tasked with and guiding
others out of the maze.
If the Jones is our disturbance of the
devil and trauma,
Loki is to serve one of God and
enlightenment.
The maze is an incredibly relevant
archetypal symbol of the human
experience.
It has been for thousands of years and
it continues to do so in our world and
in films like prisoners,
the needs of El Nerf and writer Aaron
goosy Koski.
You have shown that through adequate,
perhaps at times instinctive knowledge
of his symbol it film can take on
equality to test the ability to make us
wonder about it long after the credits
roll and not just because the symbol
fits well with its story,
but more importantly because it
expresses a truth about the human
experience that universally resonates of
us as human beings and our endless
struggle and journey towards a higher
self.
In the words of the late union
psychoanalysts Edward See Whitman,
one of the oldest images of the mystery
of life,
death,
transformation and return is the
labyrinth that depicts the way to be
unknown.
Center,
the mystery of death and rebirth,
your risk of the search,
the danger of losing the way the quests
and the finding and the ability to
return.
All right guys,
that's the end of yet another video
essay.
Uh,
if you enjoy our content,
consider supporting us on Patrion with
just a dollar a video.
In return,
you'll receive two of these stickers
with our new channel look printed on it.
Uh,
besides that,
you can follow us on social media and as
always,
thank you for watching and see you in
the next one.